Speaker 1: I'm going to play a clip for you
now of Republican Congressman Tony Gonzalez,
who represents Uvalde de Texas. He said the issue
here is mental health. Now we're going to play
the clip and then I'm going to specifically
tell you why it's pathetic for Tony Gonzales
to be talking about this. Take a look.
Speaker 3: But the root of the root of
a lot of these issues is mental health.
And, you know, this has been evident for
for a long time in this country. There is
an evil that is growing, that is rising,
that we have to we have to curb. And part of that
is mental health. Covance certainly didn't help.
Speaker 1: Okay. The root of the issue is
mental health and COVID didn't help. The
America doesn't have a particularly worse mental
health crisis than the rest of the free world. We
have a gun culture problem where people see guns
as a solution to problems. That's a real problem.
We have super easy access to guns in many states
and not enough access to mental health treatment.
But I looked into Tony Gonzales. Tony Gonzales
has regularly voted against improving health care,
which would include access to mental health. Tony
Gonzales voted no on the Women's Health Protection
Act of 2021. In June of 2020, Tony Gonzales voted
against expanding the Affordable Care Act. Oh,
it's mental illness. But he voted against
increasing access to mental health treatment.
In December of 2019, Tony Gonzales voted
against allowing the federal government
to negotiate lower prescription drug prices
in May of 2019. Tony Gonzales voted against
lowering prescription prescription drug costs. I
could go on. And by the way, in February of 2019,
Tony Gonzales voted against giving law enforcement
agencies more time to do background checks
for gun sales. And he voted against requiring
background checks for all firearms sales. And
this is why I said yesterday, when a Republican
or anyone says this is about mental illness,
ask what legislation they supported or opposed
when it comes to access to health care,
because this guy is now saying the
problem is everything but guns.
But he voted against expanding access to
health care multiple times. He voted against
simply give law enforcement more time to do the
background checks when they are actually indicated
in certain states. No, this guy wants to
point to anything that's not guns. Even if his
own voting record tells us he doesn't
actually take those things seriously.